good news tonight on the kovid 19
testing front the valley's newest site
is moving smoothly this comes after
weeks of long lines and really hours of
waiting all around town madison
kimbrough joins us live from fiesta
henderson hotel and casino with a
message from the county madison
yeah that message is that spots are open
which feels kind of odd since across the
valley it's been so hard to find a test
but here at fiesta henderson they still
have close to a thousand tests available
for today this site will operate five
days a week from noon until 8 pm
saturday through wednesday by
appointment only the drive through takes
place inside fiesta henderson parking
garage and with open availability the
county is encouraging those to make an
appointment now and get tested today as
they still have plenty of open spots to
fill
as far as tests available we have 2500
open spots total
and as they filter in we have those
spots getting filled by people taking
those appointments so
the exact number right now is probably
500 to 1 000 spots still open for people
to come take tests we have like an
express lane so if you're already
registered when you show up here you
come in here with your voucher into the
express lane it's about a six minute
wait from the start of the parking lot
to testing
an opening day on saturday went well
with no long lines or heavy traffic this
site gave out about 1200 tests with a
no-show rate of about 30 percent this
site is slated to be open for the next
20 days people can register on the
website we have up on your screen we
also have a link up on our website
reporting live madison kimbrough live
local now